it's Thursday June eleventh the thursday
before e3 but nobody told the folks at
oculus who decided to hold their own in
the press conference today and Peter
Brown you were there I just got back you
just got back work just down the road
yeah not too far I'm freaking pumped man
yeah yeah we go to battle we were all
here though because they also streamed
it they did it was on the front page of
twitch and basically everyone in the
office was tuned in watching Palmer
Luckey do his [ __ ] and you have been
reporting on viewer for a long long time
you've been you you seen more demos than
anyone else I know at gamespy what was
your take away from what they show today
so the hardware itself hasn't evolved
terribly since the last iteration that
we've seen but it's the design has been
refined and a lot of what they're
talking about right now is the
ergonomics and how it sits on your head
which is very important but the other
aspects are the software the games how
you control it how you move in space
they seem to have answers and solutions
for all this it's very exciting people
do need to understand that this is still
just the beginning you know so that the
stuff we're going to see way is not
going to be the be-all end-all of ER but
it's an incredible step forward and
seeing games like a Valkyrie which I've
tried a couple years ago like almost
here you know and I'm almost gonna be
able to have my own rift at home I'm
really really excited for that so what
what they were showing off today was the
consumer model yes is that right yes so
Justin what do you think the big sort of
key things they need to achieve with
this consumer model are what do you
think they need to like salad on well
such a difficult sell the big thing that
they showed at the presentation was
games like this was almost an e3
conference yeah like so it's kind of the
time Israel I could have done this
during e3 and there was that big focus
on games and that's what you need but
the problem is that i don't feel like
all of the games that they showed were
indicative of that VR experience a
Valkyrie of course is amazing like that
always looks great we also saw a new
game from Ted Pryce estudio de insomniac
games which oh this looks interesting
this looks neat why is that a VR game
though because we're watching this
third-person adventure yeah yeah I mean
that is a problem right i mean vr is
supposed to mimic reality reality is a
first-person experience so while it's
really exciting to see people like Ted
Pryce come on stage and some of the
other demos that were there I do wonder
if that is going to
represent or maybe harm people's
initials impression when they try VR
because I don't have a good impression
of how this game is better in VR than it
would be just on its own interesting to
see him up there obviously Indies have
been the the developers who have latched
onto this the most is this 10 million
dollar in defund that oculus are gonna
push out there there was a bunch of more
indie games that were shown some were
more impressive than others but maybe
the partnership that sort of had the
most weight was when Spencer decided to
turn up on stage that is a huge deal
it's not terribly surprising but I don't
know that we anyone thought coming
obviously sony has the Morpheus on the
way Microsoft needed an answer to that
we've seen there arc headset which is
more of the augmented reality thing so
then embracing oculus you know they
already have their relationship on the
pc side DirectX 12 has a lot of features
built into it that will help latency and
rendering for VR so I think it's a very
smart move on behalf of both oculus and
Microsoft a partner so that you can
stream xbox one games to the rift
headset you don't need to go buy
expensive pc I mean you can already do
with your phone but I think a lot of us
want this for games and if you have an
xbox one you're good to go with the rift
basically and who knows when the
Holograms is going to come out right oh
yeah ha ones not the arc but the one
thing there though is that you know
you're streaming games from your xbox
one to the headset but you're not
streaming virtual reality game yeah what
your streaming is the experience of
playing a game on a TV so the demo they
showed was you sitting in a room that
looks like a living room and there's a
big screen TV on the wall behind it the
image that you're seeing on that screen
is 2d like it would be on any TV in real
life but the flexibility it provides in
terms of being able to play anywhere in
your house and feel like you're in the
comfort of your own living room
potentially that's the promise they're
making and that's that's pretty cool
I'll be interesting this interested to
see if they do develop and announce VR
experiences that are the true
stereoscopic 3d motion tracked saying
that people will be looking for on PC
it's I guess with Sony basically jumping
in full force with morpheus people
making games for the Morpheus it is
almost a shame the d xbox one doesn't
have a like-for-like do you think this
could be something they show off at e3
Justin well I mean we're going to see a
lot of Morpheus at e3 are we going to
see more and we're going to see oculus
they've talked about that
actually getting to demo these things
are we gonna see VR experiences on the
Xbox one there I I don't think so and it
is it really that big yet like I know
that we're excited for it but I mean
just think about the the PlayStation
Move controllers anytime you have an
aftermarket accessory and this is
something we've said over and over again
when after the consoles out and you're
introducing a secondary form of
communication with that console like
Morpheus like the PlayStation Move
controllers that's not going to catch on
as big like you you're trying to get
people who already have a console
millions of people already have it are
they going to invest more money or pay
more money for a console with this thing
as an add-on probably not I think that
there is a point to be brought up though
is that you're not just buying it for
the Xbox where the move is proprietary
to PlayStation yeah the the rift will
work with the pc if you have it you know
I mean there are applications that go
beyond the console and way beyond gaming
as well like we don't need to get into
that right now but this is something
that has mass-market appeal it's it's
going to be targeted at enthusiasts
especially gamers on off the start but I
would not be shocked to see people
picking this up you know parents like
for their kids they want it but there's
also going to be the promise of stuff
for them if they don't play games yeah
so I hope that same problem doesn't
exist one of the biggest problems
forever has been at the price point the
justification of spending three hundred
dollars or wherever which is going to
cost in q1 of 2016 on a new piece of
hardware if you're buying up the
Morpheus you're like oh I can use some
my playstation and then suddenly the
oculus is actually deploy belong a bunch
of different systems it certainly makes
it a much more appealing price point and
the fact that we took connect or
Microsoft took connect out of the Xbox
both the lower the price and because
that's not a super popular piece of
hardware there's not a lot you can do
with it you have to have the killer app
we've said that over and over again as
well there has to be a killer app with
VR and there has to be a lot of reasons
to get it it can't even just one game
that's going to be enough to get the
hardcore to get that broad audience you
have to have a lot of stuff that's going
to be outside gaming I think one of the
interesting things that I really
appreciated maybe is somebody who's not
fully sort of dividend dovin into oculus
properly was the the software hub that
they have have for the unit where you
can basically go in and not only like
sort of launch all your games from that
platform but also interestingly demo
games and not demo games via video which
is the main problem we're trying to sell
fewer things to people is you need to
sort of be in the experience but there
are like sort of almost like software
demos for each of these you can sort of
just look around and experience them
yeah we've already seen that in real
life with the Samsung gear VR Samsung is
making the displays for the oculus
headsets and they've also created a
passive VR headset where you can take a
samsung galaxy note or an s6 plop it in
there you could buy that today and it
has a very similar platform to what you
were just talking about with the demos
and there are so many things it's not
just games there's film experiences
there's location experiences and those
are really cool like I'm getting to try
those out even if someone who's very I'm
still very skeptical of VR being in this
kind of filming experience exploring a
scene around you it's a really immersive
way to experience film and I'll be
honest you know uh pornography kind of
plays oh no no look let's be honest here
photography plays on our base instincts
yeah and I've heard so many developers
tell me that this exec only agreed to
come on when I showed him a porn demo
right because not everyone wants to be a
spaceship fighter right yeah but sex is
a universal thing that will probably be
the thing you know that drives this
technology forward I mean the porn
industry has legitimized so many
different technologies over the years
and that is the sort of thing that
really does like again playing your base
instincts and it's hard to not buy into
it a little bit at least in terms of the
excitement of just like yeah what like
what is this you know it's it has a
universal appeal there's a lot of things
don't when you look at high technology
like this and maybe not the best segue
into what was probably the biggest
announcement or at least the there's one
more thing the primer lucky mentioned at
the end was that they do have a new
input device sort of coming on the heels
of valve with their band okay I'll let
you use it one-handed which i think is
very it is yeah no I mean the the input
is very important and while it's great
to see that they're including a gamepad
there are inherent limitations to that
form factor you have to keep your hands
in a static position on a device and
what the touch does is that allows you
to move your hands independently valves
controller has like a grip button you
can squeeze to activate things I mean
that's
that we've not really done in gaming but
something we do in real life say opening
a door right you know you squeeze that
that handle when you grab it I didn't
see anything like that in this
controller but I also didn't get a
chance to try for myself now it's going
to happen at e3 did you get to hold it
at leat did they have any of them you
could touch I took photos but they
wouldn't let me touch no touch it no
time no touching the touch but you know
it's a it's a pretty good solution based
on just what they presented valves is
great so I have really high expectations
when it comes to this being as good or
better than but it's certainly a better
solution than they've demoed up until
this point over the past three years
well I think about the VR experiences
that I've really has sort of have stayed
with me afterwards when i tried the
Morpheus I used PlayStation Move
controllers I'm a big fan of the move
controllers as it happens but even in
that situation I was able to like pick
something up by pulling that little
trigger and that's like an incredibly
basic form of what valve are going for
or what oculus are going for her here
but another interesting thing about that
I think is that the problem we're used
to an Xbox controller we don't even look
down when we look at the buttons but if
you hand it to somebody who doesn't know
how to play those types of games or even
somebody plays playstation games you
hand them an Xbox controller it's
there's a barrier there whereas with
these there's a bit more intuition yes I
mean they're pretty limited in terms of
the inputs per device so obviously you
have the motion tracking but when it
comes to actually doing actions you have
a trigger on the back you have an analog
stick like you know device and you have
just two buttons right I mean two
buttons is very easy for someone
understand you move an inch here an inch
there there the Rays from the surface or
tactile like there you go i think that
will help break down that barrier in
terms of intimidation i want you think
about the sensors with the fingers like
obviously that's used for gestures for
instance maybe thumbs up thumbs up
radical dude it's basically like
everything you can do in surgeon
simulator that you can do in the oculus
well clarify this for me because maybe i
missed it but were they saying that it's
going to track your fingers because i
don't think that was part of it I had
what I thought he said was that there
was a mesh almost of sensors there and
that they could see individual fingers
yeah like give enough to you give it a
thumbs up it knows that you're doing
that if your point that's pretty excited
it knows somehow you're doing as good
but you know I mean wheeler there's also
the promise of a device that goes away
from
a kind of traditional controller form
factor Nintendo was kind of crazy with
the power glove back in the day but even
back then it showed the potential to be
able to close your hand move your
fingers and have the game detect what's
happening there so something like a
power glove where you can you know
literally move every finger and have
that not hit with a sensor but have the
sensors on each knuckle that's gonna be
pretty important and then you're not
worrying about buttons or anything like
that but like the power glove and again
the most important thing is that it
works perfectly like when connect came
out yeah it's like oh this is a really
cool idea that and it doesn't actually
work that great if this comes out and
it's like this is actually an amazing
experience it's gonna be a barrier to
get people to understand like no no this
is not the promise that we always get
that doesn't actually pay out this is
really good and we see a lot of people
kind of speaking down about VR right now
I think that's the problem is that
they're so focused on these early
experiences as the be-all end-all of ER
when this is just the beginning and not
to quote him and that is what he said
but that really is the way does this is
like everything started somewhere right
it wasn't until Miyamoto perfected jump
physics that platformers became really
popular but someone did right and we've
built off that so I see evidence of a
succeeding in small areas and that's
just going to get better excellent
exciting times it certainly seems like
we're definitely on the the forefront of
something very special and especially
today looking at consumer models for the
first time is an exciting prospect at q1
2016 is what they say 126 to anything on
price at all yet in the past they've
said they want it to be at or below 300
dollars I'd certainly like it to be at
or below 300 oh yes I'd be shocked if
they went above that I don't think
you're going to get those touch
controllers yet it that seems like an
extra product I think they've also said
if you're getting like a good pc along
with this will be in a 1200 ollar price
rate or will not cost more than twelve
hundred dollars so like if you have a
decent gaming rig you're probably
already set up and this will be maybe
three four hundred up top but if you're
not chasing the high end gaming
experience you definitely do not need a
pc that is that expensive yeah are so
many things you can do with video and
you know games that have very simple
qualities to them but still communicate
a great experience through the design
and base vr if you like indie games and
porn set addled it presumably if you're
looking for one of these you probably
already own a PC and
a certain that certain speed anyway
exciting stuff we haven't even reached
III and already there's a bunch of
interesting announcements around VR and
you can be sure that there will be a lot
more in the coming days so for all the
latest news on virtual reality and
everything else video games at e3 stay
tuned to gamespot com we'll see you down
in LA
you